أظهرت دراسة صغيرة نشرت في يونيو
في المجلة الاسكندنافية للطب
والعلوم والرياضة
أن الأشخاص النشطين بدنيًا
وخاصة العدائين
لديهم مخاطر أكبر لتآكل الأسنان
الآن قارن الباحثون 35 رياضيًا
بـ 35 شخصًا لم يمارسوا الرياضة
ووجدوا أنه كلما عملوا بجد أكبر
كلما قل اللعاب الذي كان لديهم
وكان توازن الحموضة أعلى في
ذلك اللعاب
الآن أحد الأسباب هو ما
يشار إليه بفم العداء ،
لذلك عندما تمارس الرياضة بشدة
، تتعرق وتميل إلى التنفس من
فمك.
يمكن أن يجففك
ويجفف هذا اللعاب
الآن ، اللعاب مهم لصحة الفم ، فهو
يحافظ على نظافة فمك ويمنع
تراكم البكتيريا ، قدم
الباحثون بعض الاقتراحات
لأولئك الذين يمارسون الرياضة بقوة أولاً ،
اشرب الكثير من الماء لأنك تحتاج
إلى الماء لإنتاج اللعاب في
الثانية بعد  تمرن على مضغ قطعة
من العلكة الخالية من السكر
أو تناول حلوى خالية من السكر
لتنشيط الغدد
اللعابية وكذلك الابتعاد عن السكر.
يشجع على نمو البكتيريا ،
تأكد من تنظيف أسنانك بالفرشاة والخيط
بانتظام خاصة بعد الجري
للمساعدة في قراءة فمك للبكتيريا
التي كان اللعاب سيطردها بعيدًا
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا هولي
فيرفر